das ist Nancy eine autokundin wie sie
sich die chinesische Staatsführung wohl
kaum besser wünschen könnte sie hat sich
vor einem halben Jahr hier in Peking ein
Elektroauto gekauft keinen ausländisches
Modell sondern ein chinesisches einen
Nino
ehrlich gesagt glaube ich das fast alle
deutschen Autos noch verbrennermotoren
haben sie konzentrieren sich nicht auf
Elektroautos wie Neustart ich hatte mir
damals auch einen Porsche taycan
angesehen aber die Reichweite war nicht
so gut sonst hätten wir vielleicht auch
ein ausländisches Modell gekauft
Nancy spricht aus was auf Chinas Straßen
längst unübersehbar ist 80% der
verkauften e-Autos sind mittlerweile
chinesische Magen mit katastrophalen
Folgen für die deutschen Hersteller zum
ersten Mal seit Jahrzehnten hat biwai
die Volkswagen in der Volksrepublik als
Marktführer abgelöst deutsche Stromer
werden zu Ladenhütern Marktanteil VW
2,4% BMW Mercedes und Audi kommen auf
nicht mal ein Prozent
wie kommt es zu diesem chinesischen
e-auto-wunder warum hat sich auch Nancy
für ein chinesisches Modell entschieden
für sie zählte vor allem eine deutlich
schnellere Lieferzeit als bei deutschen
Herstellern digitale Extras und ein
umfassender Service
Stärken sind Technologie Reichweite und
das Angebot für die Batterie wenn die
Batterien ein paar Jahren nicht mehr so
leistungsstark ist würde der Hersteller
die Batterie und das Auto zurückkaufen
und ich kann dann ein neues erwerben
diese Garantien waren der Grund warum
ich mich für diese Marke entschieden
habe
fakt ist aber auch der Umstieg auf die
Elektromobilität in China wurde von der
Stadtspitze beschlossen und seit dem
massiv gefördert Steuern beim e-autokauf
fallen weg umgerechnet 20.000 €
Preisnachlass für einen Elektroauto
keine Seltenheit auch die eigenen
Autohersteller erhalten staatliche
Subventionen und haben dadurch
Wettbewerbsvorteile gegenüber
ausländischen Firmen das schlägt sich
auch auf die Preise nieder- und auf die
Beliebtheit bei den Kunden
wenn ich mir ein E-Auto kaufe dann einen
Lee BYD oder Japan
von den drei Marken gibt es viele
spannende Modelle
mir fallen zuerst b.i.d Tesla Japan ja
diese Marken
die nationalistische Staatspropaganda
wirkt viele Chinesen meiden mittlerweile
westliche Produkte seit 2009 hat die
Regierung umgerechnet mehr als 26
Milliarden Euro zur Förderung von E und
Hybridautos ausgegeben selbst Tesla dass
ich als einziger ausländischer
Hersteller auf Chinas eh Automarkt
behaupten kann wird mit regelrechten
Dumping Preisen um überhaupt mithalten
zu können ganze 40% weniger kostet ein
Tesla in China im Vergleich zu den USA
der Kampf um den wichtigsten Automarkt
der Welt er könnte kaum deutlicher sein
auf der wichtigsten Automesse der Auto
Shanghai früher mussten chinesische
Hersteller hier oft viel Geld bezahlen
um einen stand neben einer deutschen
Premiummarke zu ergattern heute sind die
Chinesen die Messe Stars und füllen ganz
alleine mehrere Hallen sie strotzen vor
Selbstbewusstsein
ich glaube wir haben einen neuen
Industriestandard gesetzt bei der
künstlichen Intelligenz sowohl beim
autonomen fahren als auch bei smarten
Cockpits und unsere Rechenleistung ist
jetzt schon die stärkste der Welt für
Serienfahrzeuge
chinesische Autobauer mit dem englisch
wird bei seiner Show vor allem mit
Umweltschutz dass in China der Strom
allerdings noch zu knapp 70% aus
fossilen Energiequellen stammt
interessiert am Messestand keine der
Ansturm ist gewaltig
für die deutschen Autobauer eine
ernsthafte Bedrohung auf der Automesse
überschlagen sie sich fast mit ihrem
werben um chinesische Kunden
die Anspannung ist gewaltig das bekommen
auch wir Deutschen Medien zu spüren
funkelnde premierenpartys China super
Show Influenza doch ein Interview zur
Frage warum deutsche Hersteller bei
E-Autos in China so schlecht da stehen
wenn uns niemand geben
auch die Präsidentin des Deutschen
Verbands der Automobilindustrie ist nach
Shanghai gekommen sie ist zu einem
Gespräch bereit
es ist natürlich eine ernstzunehmende
wettbewerbliche Situation vor allem weil
der chinesische Staat auch massiv seine
Unternehmen unterstützt weil auch eine
bessere Situation ist was Rohstoffe was
Energie und andere Themen angeht also
erst einmal müssen wir auch unsere
eigenen Hausaufgaben machen in Europa in
Deutschland weit über die
Automobilindustrie hinaus
bei Bud etwa liegt die gesamte
Wertschöpfungskette in einer Hand von
lithium-schürfrechten in Afrika und
Südamerika über eine eigene
batteriezellenfertigung bis hin zur
Autoproduktion und Chinas Autoindustrie
profitiert von ausländischen Know-how
wir können bei Great Wall Motor drehen
bekommen Einblicke in eine der größten
chinesischen Produktionsstätten in der
Vergangenheit war das kaum möglich doch
jetzt öffnet man uns Tür und Tor mit
breiter Brust Great Wall stellt gerade
um von Verbrenner auf E-Autos was in der
Fabrik auffällt viele Roboter und
Produktionsmaschinen tragen bekannte
Namen Siemens Bosch ABB das chinesische
E-Auto Wunder fußmaßgeblich auf
europäische Hightech
ich glaube das zeichnet die chinesischen
Autohersteller aus das wirklich sehr
sehr offen mit dem Thema Technologie
Herkunft aber auch eben das Wissen von
europäischen Experten an Bord geholt
wird um am Ende das beste Ergebnis zu
erzielen
made in China soll in Zukunft für
Hightech und höchste Qualität stehen
ganz nach dem Willen der Kommunistischen
Partei china kauft in Europa Wissen und
Technik ein deutsche Autobauer werden
immer weiter abgehängt ein massives
Problem denn mit dem größten deutschen
Industriesektor könnte die gesamte
Wirtschaftskraft in der Bundesrepublik
geschwächt werden China fährt das Rennen
um den boomenden e-automat immer
aggressiver